heute zeige ich euch wie man im Haus
Tomaten aussieht und die so groß sieht
dass man am Ende richtig schöne kräftige
grüne gedrungene gesunde vitale Pflanzen
nach draußen Pflanzen kann als erstes
habt ihr die Qual der Wahl es gibt so
unfassbar viele unterschiedliche
Tomatensorten die ganz anders sind als
die Tomaten die man aus dem Supermarkt
kennt klar könnt ihr auch normal große
rote runde Tomaten anbauen aber ihr
könnt auch gelbe lila farbene grüne
gestreifte lang gezogene Spitze
riesengroße geriffelte Tomaten anbauen
also da ist ein riesengroße Vielfalt und
ich blende euch hier mal fünf
Tomatensorten ein die ich total gerne
anbaue denk dran dieses Jahr auch mal
ein paar neue Sorten auszuprobieren z.B
wandert bei mir auch dieses Jahr die
Leute Trixi ins Gewächshaus das ist eine
Tomate die ich mal bei einem Freund
probiert habe der eine Gärtnerei hat und
ich fand die so lecker dass ich dir
dieses Jahr auch anbauen werde Tomaten
sind später ja auch richtige
Sonnenanbeterinnen also die wollen ja am
liebsten das war nichts geplätzchen im
ganzen Garten bekommen und man merkt das
auch jetzt in der Kinderstube also damit
aus den Samen überhaupt Pflanzen wachsen
können brauchen die Tomaten eine
Temperatur von 20 bis 24 Grad ich sehe
die jetzt aus und wenn wir fertig sind
dann stelle ich die unter die Heizung
weil da meistens eine ganz gute
Temperatur herrscht auf der Heizung ist
es meistens ein bisschen zu warm aber
unter der Heizung ist normalerweise die
perfekte Temperatur im Tomaten
vorzuziehen denk dran dass ihr die auch
immer beschriftet weil nur so könnt ihr
auch Erfahrungen sammeln welche Sorten
ihr denn gerne mit und welche nicht und
dieser Tiefe von Tomaten ist ein
Zentimeter tief brechen wir mal über die
Erde die man verwendet ich verwende
immer torffreie Haushalt Erde oder
Kompost aus meinem Garten der richtig
schön ausgereift ist und unkrautfrei ist
also ich achte beim kompostieren darauf
dass da kein Unkraut auf dem Kompost
landet die Kompost nehme ich erst wenn
der so richtig schwarz und feinkrümelig
ist das ist jetzt die sollte Zucker
Traube die so lecker beide Optionen
entweder gekauft Erde oder
selbstgemachte Kompost sind wunderbar
dafür geeignet darin Tomaten auszusäen
viele denken immer dass der Kompost zu
scharf wäre und dass man da keine Gemüse
drin aussehen kann aber das stimmt nicht
solange der Reif ist ist das gar kein
Problem je nachdem ob ihr Aussaat Erde
oder Kompost verwendet ist das Düngen
später ein bisschen anders da spreche
ich dann gleich noch drüber hier kommt
noch die Ananas Tomate die ist auch so
gut ich freue mich schon wieder so auf
die Tomaten ich verwende jetzt hier ein
paar
recycelte Container die ich bei mir
rumfliegen hatte man kann auch hier
diese mit Deckel nehmen das ist dann wie
so ein kleines Mini Gewächshaus ihr
könnt natürlich auch quickpots verwenden
das mache ich normalerweise weil ich
nicht so viel Obst einkaufe dass ich so
viele von diesen Dingern hätte aber ich
wollte euch das einfach mal als Option
zeigen ich sehe jetzt übrigens alle
Samen nebeneinander in so ein größeres
Töpfchen ich würde auch hier so ungefähr
fünf sagen in 1 von denen Aussehen ich
drücke die Erde dann immer ein bisschen
an und dann gieße ich das ganze mit
meiner Ballbrause die hat nämlich so
einen ganz feinen sanften Strahl so dass
die Samen sich nicht weiter bewegen und
die genau da wachsen wo man sie auch
hingesät hat und dann achtet ihr einfach
in der nächsten Zeit darauf dass die
Erde immer schön feucht ist weil die
Pflanzen ja auch aufgehen und Keimen
müssen aber sie wird jetzt nicht
pitschnass sein deswegen haben die Töpfe
die man aussieht unten auch immer Löcher
so dass überschüssiges Wasser abfließen
kann und wenn ihr die Töpfe gießt dann
gießt immer in die Unterlage so dass der
Topf das Wasser von unten nach oben
hochsaugen kann nur einmal nach der
Auszeit gießt man von oben damit die
ganze feuchte Erde so richtig schön an
die Samen dran geschlemmt wird und da
keine Hohlräume mehr unter der Erde sind
und alles gut Keimen kann sobald die
Tomatenpflänzchen dann aufgegangen sind
also aus der Erde raus gucken ziehen sie
von dem warmen Raum unter der Heizung in
einen kühleres Zimmer um weil jetzt sind
Temperaturen von 16 bis 18 Grad also so
ein bisschen unter Zimmertemperatur für
die Pflanzen am allerbesten und ab jetzt
brauchen die Pflanzen auch richtig viel
Licht und das ist Knackpunkt wenn es
darum geht gesunde kräftige Jungpflanzen
anzuziehen weil gerade wenn man jetzt im
Februar oder März seine Tomaten aushält
die Tage einfach noch nicht so lang sind
und das schadet unseren Pflänzchen weil
die eigentlich 16 Stunden Licht am Tag
wollen aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache
dass wir dieses Jahr einfach alle ein
bisschen mehr Strom sparen sollten
schaut mal ob ihr vielleicht einen
Südfenster habt wo richtig schön Licht
reinkommt und dann kann man sich auch
aus Alufolie so Reflektoren bauen die
das Licht dann wieder zurückspiegeln er
wird das Licht kommt von der Fensterbank
rein da stehen die Pflanzen an der
Fensterbank und dann hat man Alu
Reflektoren hinter den Pflanzen zu der
Seite hin wo das Zimmer ist so dass das
Licht einfach wieder reflektiert wird
und ich denke das hilft schon enorm um
kräftige Jungpflanzen ohne kunstlich
vorziehen zu können wenn ihr
Pflanzenlampen verwenden wollt wir
verwenden da so bunt leuchtende so dass
man so Nachbarn wahrscheinlich alle
denken dass wir die absoluten Kiffer
werden so das ist Marmor Wasser
Patienten da LED Lampen da gibt es auch
welche die Energie sparen da sind als
andere und haben da so eine
Zeitschaltuhr mit verbunden so dass die
Lampen 16 Stunden am Tag brennen und
wenig morgens dran denken müssen die
anzumachen und abends nicht dran denken
müssen sie auszumachen das ist ganz
praktisch wenn eure Pflänzchen die
ersten Laubblätter nach den Keimblättern
gebildet haben dann seid ihr wieder
gefragt weil dann wollen die nämlich in
eigene Töpfchen umziehen dafür nehmt ihr
euch einen pikierstab oder einen
Bleistift und hebt die Pflänzchen an den
Blättern aus dem Topf raus dafür hebelt
ihr so ein bisschen in der Erde herum
dass ihr die ganz vorsichtig lösen könnt
falls die nicht am Stiel an weil der
Stiel ist extrem empfindlich also alle
jungen Pflänzchen immer an den Blättern
anfassen und dann hebt ihr die raus wenn
die ganz lange Wurzeln haben könnt ihr
die ein bisschen kacken weil das
Wurzelwachstum dadurch noch mal mehr
angeregt wird und dann ziehen die in ein
eigenes Töpfchen um dabei setze ich die
dann immer ein bisschen tiefer ein also
bis unter die unteren Blätter weil die
am Stiel nämlich dann noch weitere
Wurzeln bilden und so einfach ein
bisschen besser in dem Töpfchen drin
stehen und dieses neue Töpfchen sollte
so ungefähr in Durchmesser von 10 cm
haben damit die Pflanzen da auch genug
Platz haben um bis Mitte Mai wenn sie
dann raus gepflanzt werden durchzukommen
unsere Pflanzen sind dann so ungefähr im
Kindergarten Alter ne wenn die so zwei
Wochen alt sind dann kriegen die ein
bisschen mehr Hunger als vorher und dann
reichen denen die Nährstoffe die in der
Erde drin sind oft nicht mehr aus
deswegen wird es dann Zeit die zum
ersten Mal zu dünnen und das mache ich
immer über das Gießwasser und zwar mit
wie nasse das ist aus Zuckerrohr
hergestellt der Dünger der ist
biologisch der ist super und Tomaten
fahren total auf wie nasse ab und jetzt
kommt es darauf an ob ihr bei der
Aussaat Anzucht Erde verwendet habt oder
ob ihr euren Kompost genommen habt weil
im Kompost einfach tendenziell mehr
Nährstoffe enthalten sind müsst ihr die
Pflanzen nicht so viel düngen aber die
die in Anzucht Erde gewachsen sind auf
jeden Fall weil Anzucht Erde ganz
besonders nährstoffarm ist und wenn die
Pflanzen dann im Teenageralter sind
könnt ihr auch mal weniger gießen weil
die sich ja auch langsam daran gewöhnen
sollen dass sie schön die Wurzeln bilden
und nicht immer alles auf dem
Silbertablett serviert bekommen also ihr
seid die nicht vertrocknen lassen ne
seid immer noch lieb zu denen aber ihr
müsst jetzt nicht mehr jeden Tag oder
jeden zweiten Tag gießen die Erde sollte
immer noch ein bisschen feucht sein aber
die kann zwischendurch auch mal wieder
ein bisschen Austrocknen einfach dass
die Pflanzen angespornt werden mehr
Wurzeln zu bilden darf ich dieses Jahr
eure Tomaten Freundin sein weil ich habe
nämlich ganz ganz viele Videos über den
Tomatenanbau gemacht auf meinem Kanal
die findet ihr alle da drüben in der
Playlist zusammengefasst und schaut
gerne mal rein dann könnt ihr euch schon
mal auf die Saison vorbereiten ansonsten
geht raus und macht die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns am
nächsten Samstag wieder mit einem neuen
Video tschüss